here's what would happen if you jumped  into lake natron this is one of the most  dangerous lakes in the world and could  actually turn you into stone but  how  well taking a dip in this lake you'd be  met with water that can be up to 60  degrees celsius this would cause third  degree burns in about five seconds if  you stayed in long enough your entire  body would eventually harden this is  thanks to lake natron's high levels of  sodium and potassium carbonate  these chemicals would cause your body to  harden and eventually turn into stone  if someone were to stumble upon you  hundreds of years from now your body  would still be intact  like mummification lake natron's  extremely high levels of alkalinity  would stop the decomposition process  allowing you to be fully preserved  so